brought to you by Dark Souls 3 pre-order
now to receive a free upgrade to the day
one edition hey guys today is the 7th of
December my name is Jess McDonald and
you're watching this funny falls first
official non-beta patch is now available
on PC and it's expected to come to
consoles later this week the patch was
released in beta form through Steam
earlier this month but now it's all
ready to go for those of you who weren't
keen to risk your saved games on a patch
beta the patch notes include a bunch of
bug fixes for things like clay is
getting stuck in terminals and issues
with particular quest lines the update
also brings new PC specific features
including enabling the number pad keys
to be remapped and remapping activate
now works on quick containers the patch
is expected to make its way to xbox one
and ps4 later the three square enix
revealed that the Final Fantasy 7 remake
will be arriving as a multi-part series
in their press release Square Enix
explained each entry will provide its
own unique experience producer Yoshinori
Kitase a total mixer that the episodic
model will make the project more
manageable he said one of the main
reasons why we haven't done a remake
until now is because it's a massive
undertaking to reconstruct final fantasy
7 from the ground up with the current
technology game director Tetsuya Nomura
added that they would have needed to
make a condensed version to fit
everything into a single installment but
that there would be no point in that the
plan is to let players explore areas of
Midgard that they couldn't access in the
original although some aspects of the
original game may be cut for various
reasons he said the overall amount of
content is only going to increase black
ball game director todd howard has said
that Bethesda have lots of ideas for
future games as it expect when asked
about whether he would ever make smaller
games how it told wired I like to make
big games the team likes to make big
games we have lots of ideas we plan on
taking a break and coming back and
finding out where those ideas take us
but no we definitely don't
plan on making small things that said
but that's it is still working on pull
up for updates and the games multiple
expansions the first of which will
arrive in 2016 to get an idea of their
workflows Skyrim ship in November twenty
eleven episodes it didn't fully move on
to fall out for development until april
2013 let me know down in the comments
how you feel about the Final Fantasy 7
remake arriving in multiple parts you
can add the games but we've got stories
on a brand new uncharted force and Malik
and over watch content let me know down
in the comments what you cared about
today and I will catch you with much
more news tomorrow